[Musique]
monsieur avant toute chose je crois
utile de devoir préciser que si je suis
avec vous ce soir c'est parce que vous
me l'avez demandé et afin d'éviter toute
confusion j'ajouterai que n'étant pas
politiquement engagé j'ai accepté de
vous interroger comme j'aurais accepté
d'interroger votre adversaire s'il me
l'avait
demandé cela dit je fais partie de ces
électeurs qui se posent encore des
questions en prévision du vote de
dimanche et voici la première de celle
que je voulais vous
soumettre votre concurrent a présenté à
montsul les mines un programme social
dont un de vos supporteurs monsieur
mandz France dit qu'il est démagogique
en raison de son coup or que je sache ni
monsieur mades France ni monsieur
giscardestin ne sont incompétents en
matière d'économie alors qui di vrai
d'abord je tiendrais à vous faire
observer que c'est parce que c'est vous
et c'est parce que vous vous-même avez
un choix politique à faire que cela
m'intéresse notre discussion doit être
utile j'ai besoin d'entendre vos
objections et j'y répondrai comme je le
pourrais et j'espère aussi que ceux qui
nous écoutent en tireront
profit en effet Pier mes France a accusé
les propositions de valerie Giscard
il a dit elles sont démagogiques et cela
peut surprendre puisque il s'agit pour
l'instant du ministre de l'économie et
des finances qui n'a pas le droit d'être
démagogue et qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
démagogue ça veut dire promettre ce
qu'on ne peut pas
tenir on pourrait ajouter promettre pour
demain ce qu'on n' pas fait la
veille je pense comme Pierre Miss France
cela ne vous étonnera peut-être pas je
le pense parce que les
propositions de l'autre candidat sont
des propositions manifestement
improvisées il fait des découvertes tous
les jours et je crois bien qu'il a
découvert avant-hier la classe ouvrière
à
monsoléine son plan je n'ose à peine
appeler cela un plan c'est une série de
mesures comme le programme de Provin
tiré des comme ça sorti des tiroirs à la
dernière minute son plan qui est non
seulement improvisé est aussi très
coûteux il serait coûteux s'il était
appliqué
mais il est évident que l'autre candidat
n'y croit pas sans quoi il ne se
permettrait pas de faire ses
propositions j'ai calculé pierre Miss
français d'accord là-dessus
entre 20 et 25 milliards et 20 25
milliards en une année plus que le
programme commun tant critiqué sur ce
plan par Monsieur
liscardestin comment fera-t-il surtout
et ça c'est le plus extraordinaire que
toutes ces dépenses ne sont compensé par
aucune recette aucune proposition de
recette je dis qu'au niveau où nous nous
plaçons c'est-à-dire de la présidence de
la République on n'a pas le droit de
considérer les citoyens français de
cette façon ce sont des gens sérieux ils
savent ce que c'est qu'un budget ils
savent que lorsqu'on dépense il faut
aussi avoir des recettes ou bien on fait
de la fausse monnaie j'ajoute que les
propositions de Monsieur gardestin vous
m'avez posé la question il est normal
que je pousse ma critique improvisée
coûteuse pour va être dangereuse dans la
mesure où précisément la croissance le
progrès l'expansion l'emploi risque
d'être cassé avec des proposition
saugrenu qui n'ont ni que ni
tête j'observe que sur le plan alors
strictement politique j'ai Noé ici même
j'ai là le document puisque je l'ai pris
dans dans les journaux dans le relevé
des déclarations de Monsieur jcardestin
un certain nombre de propositions qui
viennent d'être faites comme par exemple
le refus le le la révision
du statut des pensions de vuve afin de
permettre aux veuves de recevoir la
reversion totale or précisément cette
proposition a été faite par l'actuel
ministre du Travail monsieur Gor il y a
seulement quelques semaines avant la
disparition du président Pompidou et
Monsieur giscardestin l'avait refusé
j'observe que Monsieur giscardtin
propose une augmentation de la loocation
minimum vieillesse afin de porortter à
20 francs par jour j'ai moi-même proposé
21 francs 25 quelques jours auparavant
or monsieur garfort avait proposé il y a
moins de 18 mois un plan tendant au
doublement en 5 ans de la loocation
minimum viillass et monsieur
liscardestin avait refusé j'ai noté
encore que Monsieur liscardestin propose
l'augmentation des allocations
familiales ce qui est bien nécessaire et
bien il y a simplement quelques mois il
l'a refusé également monsieur Edgar fort
j'ai noté
qu'il a réduit de moitié les demandes de
crédit pour les hôpitaux alors qu'il
vient de proposer un vaste plan pour les
hôpitaux j'ai noté qu'il fait des
propositions pour les anciens
combattants alors que la loi oblige le
gouvernement à décider la possibilité
pour un ancien combattant de prendre sa
retraite à partir de 60 ans
naturellement avec les avantages des 65
ans et que le décret d'application voulu
est signé par Monsieur G cardestin orte
à 1977 l'application de cette mesure et
en exclut les commerçants les artisans
et les travailleurs agricoles j'observe
que l'indemnisation des rapatriés
atteint des chiffres dérisoires très
loin de ce qui est dû à cette catégorie
de Français et que maintenant on promet
tout j'ai relevé cela exprès dans la
presse et dans la presse qui s'oppose à
ma politique j'ai donc des références
sérieuses je dis que ce plan est
démagogique je ne peux qu'approuver Pier
maesence soit mais vous aussi vous avez
un plan vous aussi vous faites des
promesses comment allez-vous les tenir
vous avez raison de me poser la question
je dois dire que j'ai limité mes
propositions à
regret en raison de la lourdeur de
l'héritage qu'est-ce que vous voulez
nous sommes dans une période où les prix
ont tellement monté si je l'ai déjà dit
mais je tiens à le répéter ici c'est ça
l'inflation si cela continue comme cela
a commencé cette année dans le premier
trimestre les prix monteront de 17 %
cette année 17 pour c'est énorme pour
les personnes à revenu fixes pour les
salariés pour l'ensemble des gens qui
vivent avec des modestes revenus ils ne
peuvent pas le
supporter alors mon plan lui il vise
d'abord et ce n'est pas si facile à
tenter de freiner sinon de stopper
l'inflation la hausse des prix à faire
que la majorité des françaises ne soit
pas inquiété affolé angoissé par cette
sorte de pression ce couvercle de fer
qui s'abat sur leur pouvoir d'achat et
bien j'ai fait un plan qui comporte une
première étape de 6 mois mois et j'ai
veillé à financer mes dépenses
naturellement j'ai prévu des un certain
nombre de dépenses sociales c'est normal
nous avons du rattrapage à faire il y a
des injustices trop graves qu'il faut
réparer tout de suite donc des mesures
immédiates je vais les citer elles sont
au nombre de 7 par exemple j'ai prévu
l'augmentation immédiate dès la semaine
qui suivra mon installation à la
présidence de la République en conseil
des ministres un certain nombre de
décisions comme l'augmentation SMIC à
1200 francs par mois sur la base des
40h c'est
indispensable chacun le sait bien on ne
veut pas laisser des millions de gens
dans la misère alors qu'il
travaillent j'ai prévu des mesures pour
laallocation minimum vieillesse je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure 21 francs 25 par jour
mais tout de suite ce sera décidé dès la
semaine qui suivra et non point renvoyé
au calandre grec un an comme le fait
monsieur
giscardestin même disposition pour les
grands handicapés 21 francs 25 par jour
des dispositions comparables pour les
jeunes à la recherche d'un premier
emploi vous imaginez la situation de ces
jeunes vous imaginez la situation de
leurs parents ils ont des diplômes ils
peuvent travailler ils n'ont rien cela
brise bien des jeunes foyers cela crée
le désespoir et même souvent la colère
contre notre société et bien j'ai prévu
800 francs par mois c'est-à-dire les 2
tiers du SMIC et tout cela sera décidé
tout de suite de la même façon je pense
que on doit relever les allocations
familiales j'en ai parlé de quelle façon
et bien en suivant la hausse des prix
nous avons déjà depuis quelques temps
constaté que les allocations familiales
avaient pris beaucoup de retard par
rapport à l'augmentation des salaires
laquelle augmentation des salaires a
pris du retard par rapport au prix et
ils en avaient pris depuis très
longtemps par rapport à la production ce
qui veut dire que les travailleurs ne
reçoivent pas les fruits de la croiss S
dont on parle si souvent de la même
façon je voudrais indiquer que je
m'adresse aux épargnants et que les
livrés a de Caisse d'Épargne à compté du
moment où il y en aurait un par famille
dans le cadre du plafond actuel devrait
être indexé sur la hausse des prix vous
avez des millions de gens qui
économisent ils ont raison d'économiser
il s'inquiète eu aussi et c'est très
utile à l'état c'est très utile à la
nation or ils perçoivent un taux
d'intérêt de 6 % quand les prix montent
de 14 15 peut-être 17 % ils sont volés
j'estime donc qu'il faut indexer c'estàd
aligner le taux d'intérêt sur la hausse
des prix pour l'instant je dis 15 %
enfin vieille revendication fondamentale
que chacun comprendra l'échelle mobile
des salaires mais cela est déjà admis
dans beaucoup de milieu voilà pour mes
mesures sociales et vous m' poser la
question mais ça va coûter cher
oui j'ai fait le calcul cela coûtera sur
le plan du budget de la Nation environ 9
milliards de
francs cela
coûtera aussi mais j'y viendrai il
s'agit de mesures économiques que je
n'ai pas encore abordé mais je vais
faire un panorama du coup 3 milliards
aux entreprises lorsque j'aurais examiné
de quelle façon enfin il s'agit du SMIC
je voudrais au fond approfondir la
discussion sur ce sujet mais je
craindrai qu' qu'on en ait pas le temps
car nousavons que 25 minutes
donc l'ensemble des mesures que je
prends pèseront pour 9 milliards sur le
budget y compris la réduction de la TVA
dont je parlerai tout à l'heure et pour
3 milliards sur les entreprises étant
bien entendu qu'à travers le SMIC
j'observe que dans beaucoup
d'entreprises il y a déjà des
dispositions prises pour que les 12
francs soi atteints et d'autre part si
certaines entreprises utiles ont des
difficultés je prévoirai la disposition
d'un crédit
sélectif comment financer cela 9
milliards les excédents budgétaires
existent on me dira mais alors ça c'est
un phénomène de bonne gestion vous
approuvez monsieur
iscardestin pas tout à fait dans la
mesure où c'est un budget excédentaire
parce qu'il y a l'inflation quand
monsieur jcardestin reçoit les recettes
ce sont des recettes gonflées et
gonflées par l'inflation c'est-à-dire le
résultat d'une politique fâcheuse mais
enfin il y a je le crois monsieur Chavon
Delmas m'avait dit dans un débat 14 ou
15 milliards disponibles et bien je
pense qu'il est nécessaire pour réaliser
ces mesures
sociales d'utiliser 9 milliards je reste
donc à l'intérieur d'un budget rigoureux
où les ressources compensent les dépense
et c'est cela le refus de la démagogie
je tiens véritablement à insister
là-dessus il n'est pas question pour le
responsable que je suis d'engager le
gouvernement de la France à agir
autrement que comme le ferait un chef
chef de famille qui se voudrait honnête
et qui n'irait pas dépenser comme cela
en douce en le dissimulant à sa femme un
certain nombre de petits plaisirs tandis
que elle croirait elle que le budget est
équilibré pour payer les livres de
classe ou les vacances des enfants enfin
tout ce qui fait la vie d'un
foyer naturellement il faut que des
mesures économiques viennent équilibrer
ces mesures sociales puisqu'il s'agit de
contre l'inflation dont ne parle pas
monsieur giscardesttin j'en suis tout à
fait stupéfait l'inflation c'est le mal
de notre temps sans doute est-ce un mal
international mais tout de même nous
bientôt 17 % l'Allemagne 10 % ce qui
veut dire que notre commerce extérieur
est basculé je le dirai tout à l'heure
si nous en avons le temps savez-vous que
on nous dissimule les chiffres du
déficit du commerce extérieur du mois
d'avril je crois que ce déficit est de
l'ordre de 2 milliards ce qui veut dire
qu'on va atteindre 25 milliards de
déficit dans année il faut absolument se
redresser et bien moi j'ai
prévu décision difficile croyez-le pour
un homme
politique un contrôle des prix très
sévères naturellement temporaire 3 mois
et sélectif il s'agit pas de faire tout
et n'importe quoi sur les prix
industriels essentiels on a essayé de me
faire dire ce que je n'ai pas dit en
particulier sur les prises agricoles
comment aurais-je pu le dire d'abord les
prises agricoles ils sont fixés à
Bruxelles ensuite peut-être ne
savez-vous pas moi je passe mon temps
dans mon département qui est un
département essentiellement agricole
mais les éleveurs notamment les éleveurs
de bovin connaissent des pertes
terribles à la production quelquefois
même le quart de la valeur de leur
chaptel ils ne peuvent plus
investir il faut qu'il payent les pris
industriels de plus en plus cher leurs
engrais leur leur matériel agricole donc
pas
question de bloquer les prix agricoes et
surtout pas à la production puisquil
faudrait au contraire les élevé mais
enfin indiscutablement sur les pris les
prises industrielles je répète ce que
j'ai dit d'autre
part je prévois une baisse de la
TVA une réduction au taux zéro sur les
prix sur les produits de première
nécessité ou de consommation courante on
en a beaucoup discuté avec Monsieur
giscardestin ce sont cette dispute en
tout cas il s'agit de produits comme le
lait comme le pain comme la viande de
porc comme beaucoup d'autres choses qui
sont nécessaires à la VI
la ménagère je vous prie de le croire
celle qui m'écoute pour l'instant elle
comprend ce que je veux dire le coût
environ 3 milliards sur 6 mois 6
milliards sur un an mais comme il s'agit
d'un prix comme il s'agit d'un plan de 6
mois vous avez déjà compris que cela
s'incère dans l'ensemble du coût
budgétaire que j'ai déjà précédemment
indiqué et puis la grande mesure la plus
importante peut-être consistera à lancer
un emprunt et un emprunt de 10 milliards
ce qui est important indexé sur la
hausse des prix c'est-à-dire que les
porteurs auront une certitude de rentrer
dans leur argent pour le
moins et cet emprint s'adressera au
petits porteur il ne sera plus comme
ceux qu'on a fait ces ans derniers qui
étaient uniquement souscrits par des des
banques ou des grandes sociétés des
petits porteurs cet emprunt a pour objet
essentiel d'essayer d'ponger une grande
partie de la masse monétaire qui alors
actuelle alourdit notre capacité
économique et aggrave les risques
d'inflation et d'autre part il a pour
objectif non point de compenser
d'éventuels déficit budgétairees comme
on me le dit encore une fois
mensongièrement mais en vérité de lancer
de grands travaux et donc de permettre
le plein emploi de développer notre
capacité industrielle voilà les mesures
économiques qui compenseront les mesures
sociales et qui permettront dans je le
crois dans une proportion très
raisonnable et dans les 6 mois qui
viennent non seulement de casser
l'inflation mais aussi de porter la
croissance aux environs de 5 % et dans
l'immédiat c'est-à-dire dans les 15
jours qui suivront l'élection de
répondre aux besoins des catégories les
moins favorisées voilà mon plan
économique et social il est beaucoup
plus modeste que je ne le voudrais mais
je suis bien obligé de tenir compte du
triste héritage que j'aurais assumé bien
une question monsieur est-ce que vous
avez l'intention de lancer votre emprunt
avant ou après avoir nationalisé les
banques d'affaires et le crédit le
problème de la nationalisation ne peut
pas se poser dans l'immédiat attention
que ce soit pas interprété comme un
recul car cette nationalisation de neuf
groupes industriels et du crédit qui me
paraît absolument nécessaire qui a
commencé d'être entrepris par le général
de GA en 1945 ne peut intervenir que par
la loi c'est-à-dire que cela ne dépend
pas de la décision du Conseil des
ministres ni de la volonté du Président
de la République mais du vote du
Parlement à partir de là cela rejette en
effet ces dispositions à plus tard étant
bien entendu qu'elles seront prises
aussi dans le cadre de la situation
telle qu'elle sera examinée et des
équilibres indispensables je constate
toutefois que vous n'avez pas parlé
parmi les mesures que vous comptez
prendre de l'impôt sur le capital oh oui
vous me dites ça parce que vous êtes
sensible à ce que l'on répète partout
naturement ENF puisque vous êtes
vous-même électeur ça vous intéresse et
après tout vous possédez peut-être un
petit bien et vous n dites si on m'en
prend toute une partie ça ne me fait pas
plaisir c'est un des bords d'attaqu les
plus rudes contre mes propositions
seulement voilà il faut parler clair
qu'est-ce que je demande je demande pour
plus tard je veux dire quand le
Parlement pourra en décider cela non
plus n'est pas de mon ressort ni du
ressort du gouvernement je demande un
impôt sur les grandes fortunes alors
aussitôt on dit un impôt sur le capital
le le jeune cadre qui vient de bâtir sa
maison et qui s'inquiète en se disant on
va me prendre une partie de de mon
capital on va m'imposer 5000 6000 10000
francs tout cela c'est une mauvaise
plaisanterie il s'agit d'atteindre des
grandes fortunes qui se sont édifiées et
cet impôt sur le capital ou sur les
grandes fortunes il existe déjà dans des
pays où le capitalisme est roi pensez
aux États-Unis d'Amérique où il y a
impôt sur les grandes fortunes pensez à
l'Allemagne de l'Ouest pensez à la
Suisse alors je pense que c'est vraiment
faire une politique très réactionnaire
que de refuser cet impôt là mais je
pense aussi que c'est une tactique
électorale qui n'est pas honnête que de
penser que nous pourrions que je
pourrais porter atteinte à la
propriété gagnée par le travail par
l'effort et par l'intelligence de mes
concitoyens je suis moi-même un petit
propriétaire et croyez-moi j'y
tiens j'observe d'ailleurs oui oui vous
me posz cette question et je pense à
quelques autres par exemple j'ai entendu
dire que j'aurais l'intention de bloquer
les compescourants
oui enfin soyons sérieux bloquer les
comptes courants et pourquoi faire
j'ai entendu dire que je voulais
supprimer le régime des retraite
complémentaire pour les cadres je m'en
suis expliqué déjà hier dansond avec le
régime général oui mais n'est-ce pas le
projet de la gauche consiste
naturellement c'est une perspective
lointaine ça peut pas se décider comme
ça consiste à décider qu'il faudrait que
tous les salariés a une retraite
correspondant à 75 % du traitement de
leurs 10 meilleures années 10 meilleures
années de carrière
ça c'est un objectif très louable la
preuve c'est qu'actuellement les cadres
avec le régime général et le régime
complémentaire les mieux placés ne
dépassent pas 67 ou 68 % bon ça c'est un
objectif c'est lointain naturellement si
on pouvait le faire ce serait bien mais
tant que cela ne sera pas fait il n'est
pas question j'en donne l'assurance
solennelle il n'est pas question de
toucher au régime complémentaire des
cadres et tous ceux qui disent le
contraire font une opération électorale
de mauvaise àoi qui rabaisse notre débat
car voyez-vous vous le sentez bien
depuis la première minute à quel point
j'éprouve la noblesse du combat dans
lequel je suis engagé et je souhaiterais
vraiment que Monsieur J cardestin veille
bien faire comme je l vite c'est-à-dire
que c'est un débat qui doit élever la
conscience des Français et leur
permettre de choisir gravement les
intérêts de la France puisque vous
parlez de débat monsieur j'ai noté qu'au
cours de votre face- à faceace avec
Monsieur Giscard desestin vendredi
dernier à la télévision il vous a posé à
au moins deux reprises la question
suivante qui était si j'ai bonne mémoire
comment comptez-vous vous y prendre pour
revaloriser le franc comme vous le
promettez vous n'avez pas répondu mais
j'ai pas répondu parce que ça a été posé
tout à fait à la fin et qu'il m'était
difficile de revenir sur des sujets
économiques alors que nous étions déjà
engagés ou en direction d'avoir à
discuter et de politique étrangère et de
politique générale et j'ajoute que j'ai
fait une conférence de presse là-dessus
dès le début de ma campagne et que je
pensais que Monsieur J destin avait eu
l'obligeance de m'écouter qu'est-ce que
je veux dire par là j'ai déjà parlé il y
a quelques instants du déficit de notre
commerce extérieur qui
s'aggrave il faut absolument tenir bon
et tenter de défendre le travail
français la monnaie représente le
travail des Français et il faut que le
travail français se revalorise dans la
compétition internationale or c'est la
débandade on a dévalué il y a quelques
années on a dévalué il y a quelques mois
avec le flottement du franc pendant ce
temps l'Allemagne a quatre fois réévalué
et bien il faut avoir une volonté et
décider de défendre le franc et de dire
que dès les circonstances le permettront
naturellement ça ne se décide pas 3 mois
à l'avance on dit pas tel jour je
réévaluerai le franc mais il faut avoir
une volonté il faut faire comme l'ont
fait nos anciens quand ils se sont
accrochés à la Marne ils ont dit et bien
maintenant on ne lâche plus on tient le
terrain on s'accroche afin de repartir
en avant et non point en arrière ma
volonté elle est de revaloriser le franc
et de permettre son retour au sein de ce
qu'on appelle son des langages de
technicien le serpent communautaire
c'est-à-dire la communauté de l'ensemble
des pays en dehors de l'Italie de
l'ensemble des pays du continent de
l'Europe des neu voilà ce que je crois
nécessaire c'est une volonté nationale
ça nous fera payer d'ailleurs moins cher
nos importations et ça servira tous ceux
qui dispose à l'heure actuelle de petits
et de moyens
revenus une dernière question
monsieur vous avez dit au cours de la
campagne ou plutôt votre adversaire vous
a dit vous êtes un homme du passé vous
avez répondu le passé c'est vous alors
Sion vous suit l'un et l'autre nous
allons nous retrouver lundi avec un
président quel qu'il soit qui sera un
homme du passé et avec dans
l'opposition à peu près 50 % de Français
qui seront eux-mêmes des hommes du passé
puisquils auront voté pour un homme du
passé qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
situation pour répondre à votre question
il ne s'agit pas de l'état civil des
deux
candidats moi je suis né en 1916 le 26
octobre si on veut le savoir et quand
j'écoute monsieur
giscardestin et quand je vois ce qu'
l'entoure j'ai quelquefois l'impression
qu'il est né avant
1789 si nous avons aujourd'hui sur le
plan de l'état civil près de 10 ans de
différence croyez-moi ça va vite ce
n'est pas le problème soyons sérieux le
problème était de savoir quels sont les
forces politiques et sociales
économiques aussi qui supportent ou qui
soutiennent nos
candidatures et bien moi j'observe tous
les sondages le démontrre ils sont
d'accord là-dessus depuis le premier
jour que ma candidature a derrière elle
ou autour d'elle l'ensemble des forces
de la jeunesse et l'ensemble des forces
du travail et de la production c'est un
événement colossal dans notre histoire
cela représente une valeur dynamique qui
de toute façon façon se projettera dans
l'avenir prochain je suis donc un
candidat soutenu par les forces de
l'avenir et c'est la seule chose qui
m'intéresse du côté de Monsieur
giscardestin je ne dis pas que tous ceux
qui ont voté pour lui les 32 % du
premier tour tous ceux qui voteront pour
lui le 19 mai soit des forces
réactionnaires non pas du tout je pense
simplement qu'on les trompe et qu'ils ne
savent pas encore c'est pourquoi je veux
m'expliquer y compris
devant les électeurs qui n'ont pas voté
pour moi et j'ajouterai y compris pour
les électeurs qui ne voteront pas pour
moi mais ce sont mes frères ils sont
français comme moi et je leur dois mes
explications et bien je dis que il
risque d'être trompé par des petit
groupe d'une société privilégiée
dominante qui vient de loin dans notre
histoire qui représente les anciens
chatau fort les dominations des sociétés
multinationales la domination des
privilégiés et je dis que c'est ça
et qu'il faudrait en finir dans la
fraternité naturellement sans vouloir
punir ni frapper personne mais aussi
dans la
justice